it was hard I think everybody had a lot
of emotions coming in and then the
videos the music you know it was just
one of those moments you know one of our
legends icons in the world not just our
game passing away is one that really
really really tough tough night so I
think the game started off slow because
of that you know it's hard to be excited
about a game when you had this type of
situation but I think both teams found
it after you know the first half of the
first quarter it was competitive game
you know a great game what was the most
challenging part about playing in this
one this
you know what we we played this game you
play it because we love it and you know
you want to come out of this game with
something that you're proud of whether
it's having a big night getting a big
win winning streaks all those things but
it's hard to come out of something like
this being proud you know given the
situation you know what's on our hearts
right now so I think that was probably a
selfish thing you told us before the
game that because of the competitor that
Kobe Bryant was you could only think of
one one way to honor him tonight tell me
what that was come out here and play our
hearts out you know this is the the one
thing that we know for sure we had in
common with Kobe beloved his game and we
here so you know we might as well come
out and honor him in that way and I
thought we did it you did that okay
thanks Damian Mike